let's switch gears now and bring in
another place where the storm is
happening but this is man-made and
man-caused
it's really the administration cause and
that is the crisis at our border let's
bring in texas
congressman and former sheriff troy
nails congressman welcome back
good morning thank you brian congressman
we're focusing on how many people come
across
on their own and what we're going to do
with them when they don't have unsavory
uh uh intentions what about the criminal
activity where they don't want to be
apprehended
well we know that now it's the state of
texas
and it's our governor governor abbott
having to react
and actually respond proactively
to this crisis at the southern border he
is
augmenting the border patrol with
department of public safety officers
national guard because our governor has
been there before and he realizes that
there is
a crisis at the southern border and
still today
after how many weeks of this now the no
borders biden administration is
continuing to say there is no crisis
his homeland security director saying
there's no crisis
wake up people wake up and understand
that this is a serious issue for the
american people and it must be addressed
and it must stop today it must they're
not even letting our cameras they're not
letting our reporters you know steve
ducey's son
is at the white house and he asks all
the time to go down there to see what
these what's happening inside these
shelters or these facilities they won't
let anyone in they're not allowing
media ride-alongs and they say you have
to send your request now to the
department of homeland security
and uh and maiorkus who is who works for
president obiden he was appointed by
president obiden
he's still not calling it a crisis
listen to what he said
you said earlier in your testimony that
the situation at the border is
undoubtedly difficult
well given the the tremendous rise in
surge of individuals coming to the
border
wouldn't it be fair to call it a crisis
because that's what your agents are
calling it
i'm not spending any time on the
language that we use
i am spending time on uh operational
uh response to the situation at the
border
what's your response when you hear that
i mean you're in law enforcement you
were in law enforcement you have friends
down there
what did they think was going to happen
when you're out there proactive you're
out there telling these people
come on into our southern border it's
open we're open for business
and now all of a sudden he's coming out
there and he's trying to pump the brakes
and say don't come now
do you remember over the summer time
when you saw all of this civil unrest
across our country and there were calls
for defunding the police
well when you call for defunding the
police what do you think was going to
happen
you're going to see an increase in crime
and that's what we've seen in our cities
across our country
so now when you you tell these people i
come on into our southern border
you're going to see an increase in crime
you're going to see an increase in
migrant
migration you're going to see an
increase of victims
i mean our governor addressed it the
other day talking about the number of
these
individuals being sexually assaulted
sadly sad
sad state of affairs and to your point
about the crime
we've got a little bit of tape and this
shows
automatic weapon fire one of the people
who took it
was a former texas border security
captain
and it is you can hear the weapons in
the background and it's horrifying
listen to this
we're seeing infants
gunfire done about them okay can you
turn real quick so they can hear it
oh yeah there we go we're still live
congressman that's what you hear in a
war zone that
is some guy sitting on the other side of
the rio grande river
it reminded me what i saw and heard in
afghanistan in 2008
and what we're seeing so we have a
crisis at the southern border it's
dangerous
it's dangerous for the american people
because the human traffickers
are benefiting from this the drug
traffickers are benefiting from this
joe biden's administration is aiding and
abetting
in the trafficking of persons he's
complicitness
and it must stop he must reverse course